et canadiens se rendront aux urnes le 21
octobre
le compte à rebours pour que le canada
sort des barrages du courant des chats
cuche et trudeau est officiellement
lancée dès le premier jour de la
campagne
il est évident que les voisins soleillé
de justin trudeau sont obscurcies par
son bilan snc-lavalin la loi sur la
laïcité s'impose dans la campagne à
douchy s'engage à ne pas contester ou
alors que rich beem et maîtrise les
parties égrènent leurs promesses les
libéraux veulent bonifier les programmes
existants
les conservateurs éliminer le déficit et
ramener des crédits d'impôts dé stephen
harper leur équipe l'enrayer d'après
puisqu'il propose aujourd'hui les mêmes
politiques la paix
j'ai parfait mais le chef libéral est
rattrapé par son passé
j'aurais pu le faire vous aurait dû
savoir que j'aurais pas dû
mais
d
c'était une erreur maquiller son visage
ombreux sénateurs les autres chefs
refuse d'aller aussi loin
la réaction de jazz meeting ému par son
authenticité
je veux vous dire que vous avez valeur
vous êtes aimé la marche pour le climat
et la visite de la jeune greta thoune
berg met à l'avant plan les promesses
environnementales ou premier débat en
français le bloc québécois est accusé de
vouloir semer la zizanie tu legolas ce
trouble et c'est toujours décrit chaque
année pendant qu'un douchez est pris à
partie sur l'avortement toi un bouchon
est ce que vous croyez qu'une fin
devrait avoir le choix
ce qui le force à préciser quelques
heures plus tard j'ai toujours être
clair les débats de la commission font
entrer en scène
elisabeth me et maxime berreby la radio
n'empêche que justin trudeau est
vilipendé de toutes parts ce taux est
alors que le vent semble tourner pour le
npd et le bloc québécois
les questions qu'on pose c'est est-ce
que le cadavre le corps commence à
brouiller lui aujourd'hui vous me
demandez si ambit entraînement réseau
partie les flèches veulent dans toutes
les directions
il vise à mettre à la raison l indicible
qui vont faire attention qu'on voit
atteindre les cibles de paris mais elle
va détruire l'économie ici ces messieurs
publie ici mais ces messieurs pipeline
encore et monsieur trudeau g passe aussi
si monsieur public
moi je suis jack médecin je vais jamais
imposé au public sur le québec
voter pour le bloc c'est voter pour les
libéraux à inventer pour le blog c'est
voter pour les conservateurs voter pour
le bloc
c'est vrai pour le québec avec un nombre
record des lecteurs au vote par
anticipation les chefs exhorte les
canadiens et ne faut pas choisi le port
on peut choisir de l'espoir quarante
jours plus tard il est évident que le
choix se fera en ontario et au québec
oui vous êtes maître chez vous m
maître de vos institutions et maître de
vos aspirations suggère me donnait
l'impression de nos mains
évincé qui multiplie les déclarations
d'amour pourront venir la maison avec
ses sacs de neige on a un choix
fondamental à faire lundi un choix lundi
qui va avoir des échos pour des
générations